first we're showing one right back
let's go
all right let's get right into it bro so
how'd you actually get into numerology
and everything like 9 11. 9 11 11 was
the turning point in my life I woke up I
saw the Twin Towers going down and I
thought I was watching a Bruce Willis
movie Die Hard you were in New York no
no I was in Cleveland Ohio but I saw it
on TV and I thought it was the movie Die
Hard and then when I realized what
happened I went outside smoked one for
everybody you know that you know lost
their lives and then
um I I saw there was flight 11 that hit
the World Trade Center on 911 I'm like
hmm that's that's interesting and then I
started thinking wait a second the
police code for emergency is 9 11 and
then I'm like wait let's go into all the
facts New York's the 11th state in the
Union New York City 11 letters
Afghanistan 11 letters the Pentagon 11
letters I'm thinking whoa what the hell
is this and then I started looking at
more stuff like the Twin Towers look
like an 11 side by side they both have
110 stories yeah at this point I'm like
okay this is no coincidence and
basically at that I I saw smoke I didn't
know where the fire was coming from but
at that point I realized someone's doing
something on purpose I just didn't
understand why and then that's where my
love of History came in because I always
loved history that's by the way
something you kids nowadays are lacking
World War one ended on 11 11 at exactly
11 o'clock they're still firing bullets
at each other at 10 55 at 11 they
stopped so as soon as I connected 911 to
that event I'm like someone's doing
something on purpose I just didn't
understand why there's no books on the
subject there's no internet the
internet's just not what it is today
back then there's no research on this no
one's talking about this and you know
most people thinking I'm oh this dude's
crazy and then a little bit later I
figured out that Al-Qaeda was founded on
August 11th that's the one they blame
for 9 11 and their two other biggest
attacks in Spain and India both happened
on March 11th in July 11th what do you
know still a coincidence huh what what's
the power of 11 like why would they do
that is a master number in numerology
and it's also emotional energy
so when you have 11s all over the place
you can expect people to be more
emotional and that's why they have these
terrorist attacks under 11 energy
because they know it'll get the people
riled up
were there like ancient societies into
numerology like the pyramids and that
kind of stuff
um people in Babylon uh when it comes
down to you know Atlantis this is all
they used because this is basically for
you people to understand what numerology
is it basically represents energy
there's some people out there who can
read auras there are some people out
there that can look at you and see what
is magnifying off you and based off the
colors it will be able to say what type
of mood you're in if you're trustworthy
all that other stuff but here's the
thing about numerology we don't have to
see those colors we don't have to see
orders as long as we can interpret the
numbers they will tell us what the
energy is and whenever it's an 11 day
you expect people to be emotional 11 is
also the number of Charisma so people
who are born on the 11th tend to have a
lot of Charisma there's two ways to be
11's you can be born on the 11th like
the top podcaster in the world what's
his name
top guy in the world is born on August
11th he happens to share the same
birthday as the top wrestler of all time
Hulk Hogan the Real American Hero he was
born on the 11th so again it's
generational
you understand what I'm saying it's not
just one generation with that birthday
it's another one too who is pretty much
the top guy when it comes to streaming
in Miami it's Nico Aiden there you go
Aiden and when's he born on the 11th
so when it comes down to it people who
are born in the 11th have natural
Charisma you might look at Aiden be like
whoa how'd this guy get on he's not
really talented but people are drawn to
him because he's born on the 11th and
that's why he's in that position so like
what about all the people born on 11th
that don't have influence are they just
like they're not using their abilities
to their potential so they basically
like have more potential because they're
born 100 Candace Owens came out of
nowhere and did it Candace Owens was not
a plant Candace Owens was not
manufactured and she was born on the
29th what's 209. 11. there you go now
it's not just when it comes to people
who are influencers because I just don't
want to go there let's go to things that
are much more important than influencers
would you agree that the president of
the United States tends to be a little
bit more important than these
influencers we're talking about I'd say
so okay Barack Obama born 8-4 in 1961
841961 adds it to 29 29 is 11. what does
that tell you that tells you that Barack
Obama probably the guy with the best
mouthpiece in the since John F Kennedy
and John F Kennedy's born on the 29th
209 is 11 is an 11 life path who else is
an 11. uh do you remember you might not
but there's a guy called Ronald Reagan
he was the uh Republicans Messiah and
Ronald Reagan was an 11 life path uh
let's go to Joe Biden is an 11 life path
he's old but if you look at his past he
used to have a lot of Charisma when he
was a lot younger do a lot of like the
so numerology is typically with a lot of
like these feminist [__] but like 100
what do they have any of it right or
they have just a whole different version
of it no they they just make stuff up
there's no accountability you understand
when I tell you something I'm throwing a
birthday I'm throwing an event behind it
so people can be like yo look it up
yourself don't believe me look it up
yourself I'm actually being accountable
by telling you what I believe and then
giving you information to back it up
there's no accountability of these women
so obviously they're not going to give
you the same they're going to tell you
uh you're gonna meet someone with the
letter s on Tuesday and it's gonna be a
wonderful day
and guess what the sun's going to come
up tomorrow too so again there's a
difference between what I do and what
these broads do okay
um I'll give an example one time I
checked this woman her name is Allison
she's been a numerologist for 40 years
and she's selling matchmaking advice and
again I have no problem with it
capitalism is wonderful if you have a
skill sell it the thing is she's
divorced three times
so if you're selling matchmaking advice
and you're divorce three times don't you
think that's kind of
um you know fraudulent yeah okay so I
check her on this and she tells me I
hate women
again no accountability no nothing I
just hate people because they disagree
with me no I hate people because they're
fraudulent I hate people because they go
against they don't have any morals I
hate people because they're thieves I
hate people because they don't actually
represent their true selves that's
that's a reason to basically hate
someone but for being truthful no you're
just trying to better someone else why
is the birthday so important like the
day you're born because when you're born
you're imprinted with energy and like
even like a C-section that's like the
same thing even even I both my kids are
C-sections what about the day you're
conceived does that have anything that
might be a weird question but
they're a little bit too smart uh we'll
talk about that off oh that's an
off-camera one that's an off-camera one
but yes things do matter everything
matters but just to go back to what I
was saying um
for instance let's take you what's your
birthday August 20th 2003 okay so you're
born August 20th 2003 because you're
born in 2003 you're gonna have the
characteristics of any of the goat
energy because that is the year of the
go so you have to think of it like this
the Earth is spinning and once every 12
years it spins with different energy and
whenever you're born you're imprinted
with that energy that it's spinning with
so it's imprinted on you so that means
because you're a goat you're gonna have
good goat ears and you're going to have
bad ax here's the next year the ox is
2033 that's probably a year that you
have to lay low a little bit the next
goat years 2027. I'm willing to bet that
you're gonna [__] blow the hell up
faster than any time in your life that
year uh examples I'm sure people know
who Andrew Tate here is
Andrew Tate was born in 1986 the year of
the tiger when he come up 2022 the year
of the tiger what do you think that's a
coincidence but someone could say yo
that's one example that doesn't mean
anything and you know what I agree with
you don't you know someone named sneak
out yeah
you're the tiger he got his first Milli
last year 2022 the year of the tiger
there's another guy called Mr Beast he's
born 1998 year the tiger and what'd he
do last year he got a billion dollar
evaluation for his YouTube he's
basically became a billionaire last year
yeah Tiger Tiger but you know what
someone could say yo that's not enough I
got one more for you you know who Tom
Cruise is Tom Cruise is born 1962 the
year the tiger the first Top Gun movie
came out 1986 the year the tiger he
became a star and then last year the the
second Top Gun movie came out 2002 2022
the year of the tiger he's a tiger he
was the highest paid actor in Hollywood
last year so again not one not two not
three but four examples of how this
works in everyday life this is what the
women won't do they will not give you
these type of examples they will just
say trust me guess what we don't trust
you
it's that simple I need evidence I am
the biggest critic in the world that's
why I'm trying to tell people I was the
biggest critic I need evidence I need
proof and that's why I'm able to provide
so much when you ask me questions
there's no hesitation how does this
incorporate with religion because I have
a very religious audience and a lot of
them probably say like Haram all this
kind of stuff listen
um first of all I respect the Muslim
faith I believe
um Islam will do a lot to cleanse in the
centuries in the decades to come
um but listen it's very simple if you
believe in Allah if you believe in Jesus
Christ if you believe in anything any
religious book has they they're all
written in different languages the Torah
the Quran the Bible all different
languages they only have one thing in
common
numbers
every single one of your holy books has
numbers and they're all in the same
shapes see the languages are different
but the numbers are all the same and
what that basically tells you is this
it's a universal language it is a gift
from God
it is that simple if you this is a
virtual reality
this is all a virtual reality Spiritual
Beings in a human existence exactly this
is all a virtual reality and numerology
and astrology are the cheat codes in
life if you learn these codes you get to
navigate life a lot easier
what if some of like the the numerical
coincidences in the Holy books like I
know I know like the moons mentioned
what 28 times in the Quran the sun
365. let's just put it this way
um
without going to every single one the
Quran the Bible in the Torah are all
coded
and they're all coded with the numbers
and percentages
um I believe 70 of the Earth is water
and um somehow percentage equals the
same in the Quran where it's mentioned
again I'm not an expert on this but I
know there's codes in the Quran they're
codes in the Bible they're codes in the
Torah and if you take the time to study
them you're gonna see that they
basically all have one thing in common
numbers and again numbers are the one
universal language men lie we know women
lie but Numbers Never Lie and though
that's just the case two plus two is
always going to equal four no matter how
hurt your feelings are no matter if you
need a safe space or not it's always
going to add up to the same thing so
what people have to understand is
you don't need to believe me I'm not
here to sell you on anything okay
what you need to believe
is to trust the people in positions of
power
because they're the ones using this
information
I'm a millionaire okay I'm not a
billionaire though the billionaires are
the ones using this stuff and they'll
never tell you I'll give you some
certain ways they hide this stuff in
society
33 is the number of influence I've told
you this before
who is the most influential dead man in
the world
Adolf Hitler no who is the most
influential dead man in the world
Jesus Christ there you go some people
would say Muhammad but here's the thing
Jesus Christ is in the Quran too Jesus
Christ is not only in the Quran he's
also in the Bible so he is the most
famous dead man in the world and he died
at what age
33.
why did he die yeah you should have
slipping why did he die at age 33 why
very simple
because at age 33
that gave him influence to connect Jesus
Christ with that number because they
connected Jesus Christ with the number
33 that makes it the number of influence
so he almost made it the number of
influence by dying at 33.
um I think it made him you think it made
him
what about like
the time you die affecting
um your afterlife have you thought about
that at all yeah you like asking
questions I have 100 non-disclosure oh
these I'm asking like the sit outside
questions yeah I'm a gatekeeper guys
there's only so much I'm gonna say
publicly all right I have no problem
admitting that either
I have another one
um noise frequencies so like the Elites
in Hollywood purposely
um orchestrating the music to suppress
people's noise frequencies 100 is this
another non no no we can talk about that
um they like to most people's heartbeat
hits 72 beats per sec per hour per a
minute so what they want to do is they
want to match music that matches the
heartbeat and when they do that they
know they can subconsciously control
people's minds that's why you know a lot
of music is negative like I won't let my
kids to listen to certain music it's sad
music there's a lot of sad music that's
popular rap is just all garbage
even like the women like this is what I
tell you about that think about this
Destiny's Child oh yeah every single
song about Destiny's Child is yo get rid
of your man yo this guy's a loser yo get
your bag and be out women hear this
stuff all the time we know how easily
women are emotionally manipulated they
always vote for Democrats so we
understand that so what you have to
understand is why because they know how
to control people with music they know
how to control people with sounds they
know how to control people with colors
think about this Donald Trump whenever
he was uh doing a public event whenever
he had a red tie he was very aggressive
red is a very aggressive energy when he
had a blue tie he was more with a tip
one yeah McDonald's uses red to incite
hunger exactly exactly so red doesn't
just uh inside Hunger
not only anger but sexual urges too
really think about it think about it
think about the movie The Matrix the
Lady in Red the lady in red that
symbolizes that stuff The Matrix is such
an amazing movie but what do you think
it was me it was made by like like
[__] lesbians it was it was well you
can't I don't believe we live in that
type of Matrix where there's some kind
of computer in the back of us our head I
don't believe that I think it's more of
a spiritual Matrix so what you have to
understand is the best lies have little
troops so yes there is some truth in the
movie The Matrix but it's not that we're
connected to some machines this is more
of a spiritual prison than a machine
prison
um you know there's something called
karma you know if you do bad things
karma is attached to your soul and
whether you bring incarnate in this
knife or the left or the next the karma
is attached to you do you think you
reincarnate as humans or you could
potentially come back as animals like
some religions I think I think if you
live a very very
negative life
um yes you could devolve as an animal
really I think if you're a murderer and
I'm not talking about people who murder
out of Rage or someone who committed
manslaughter killed someone by accident
but if you're some kind of bloodthirsty
murderer yeah maybe you've got you
devolve into a wolf next time maybe you
devolve this something you know more
primitive so you can use those instincts
um people humans are supposed to do a
reason
obviously Wars violence solves a lot
that's why we have World War One World
War II but the whole point of being a a
human is to try to find a reasonable
solution before you come to violence so
yeah I think if people are just violent
for no reason they could devolve the
animals yeah I just read something too
that like circumcision at Birth is a
part of like if you stay uncircumcised
that um that flesh helps you remember
your past life in like the first year
which is weird I would never kill myself
like I'm not gonna go too deep into like
the abortions I got you I got you I
probably shouldn't either but um you
know there are certain Customs that are
done to society you know and they lie
that's you know for your benefit but
it's actually you know I wonder what
yeah I'll give an example uh fluoride in
water they say uh fluoride is good for
your teeth you think the government
cares that much about your teeth
you really think the government cares
that much about your teeth the truth of
the matter is everyone has a pineal
gland calcified and when you have a
pineal gland that is basically your um
your third eye if it's open if it's open
it can help with your third eye uh
people haven't calcified and what do you
want from these people you're not going
to get much from them because they don't
even understand this type of thinking
and again this is all done by Design the
people in positions of power don't want
competition and that's why it says in
the Bible in in in the Quran the
numerology and astrology is Haram
because the the people who wrote those
books they want to have the information
but they want to scare you from having
it too it is pretty interesting because
if they thought it was complete [__]
I doubt they would even acknowledge it
in the books
100 it's pretty sad to see how many
people are so close-minded in the chats
and whatnot like I'm here just asking
questions learning you'd think more
people would want to listen listen I
want you religious folks to understand
something about me
I support the family unit I've been
happily married for 20 years I have kids
I'm not I support the nuclear
um family I have helped politicians in
the past
um what I'm basically trying to tell you
is God told you to think
it even says in the Quran think
it says in the Bible think if you want
to say astrology is evil fine
let's take all the astrology aside let's
actually give you that what are you
gonna say about my numbers what are you
going to say about numerology are you
really gonna say numbers are evil are
you really gonna say that I'm some kind
of Satan or some other kind of [__]
because you disagree with me
why would you think that way if my
numbers are all over your holy book
maybe it's you that should start [__]
thinking
do you think NPCs are actually real like
some people don't have souls yes I 100
believe that as a matter of fact to take
a Bible term
um the 144. I think there's uh basically
144 million people on Earth with souls
and I think the rest are NPCs and
considering there's seven billion people
on the planet that tells you a lot I
think the NPCs are here to keep us in
line
the ones with souls to make sure if you
have a great idea oh no that [__] ain't
gonna work dude give it up man they're
here to keep you down deflate you and
sometimes NPCs can be in the same family
too yeah I know what I'm saying that
they want to keep you down like whenever
you have this Grand idea they wanna
here's the thing about me I remember
um in 2001 when I started doing
numerology astrology and I saw something
here you know all the all the
numerologists of that time are broke
um you know it wasn't really a place I
had mentors or anything like that and I
said I was gonna you know make this
famous and I was gonna basically
um make a living off this
um and I have and I've and just so you
guys know because I know some people
only respect good capitalism and I am a
good capitalist I'm a millionaire many
many times over I live in a very very
expensive area code and when it comes
down to it money is not an issue I'm not
bragging when I'm basically trying to
say is what I do works what I do works
and you might worship God I serve God
difference
what's the power in the number 33 I mean
I'm 13. 13 is the number of the Matrix
itself Matrix starts with m m is the
13th letter you know um there's 13
ruling families in uh the world there's
you have the Rothschilds on top and then
you have the 12 other Pinsir families
they have that
OnePlus 12 code equals 13 all across
Society example one judge 12 jurors one
plus twelve system
um so it's a systematic number they they
so why do they make you homage numbers
why do they make you fear it it's a
homage number because you gotta fear the
elite you understand
it's a homage number they pay homage
that way McDonald's Big M M is the 13th
letter let's go to the Philadelphia
76ers they're gonna tell you they're
called they're called the Philadelphia
76ers because of 1780 1776 the truth of
the matter is how come they're not
called the 1776 or they call it the
76ers seven plus six is what 13. uh
there's there is the 1849 year old
Russian San Francisco you think that's
intentional not because not because
76ers rolls off the tongues 100 what
about the 49ers
come on man
they're gonna say it's because of the
1849 Gold Rush but that they have cover
but why to 13 if that's a if that's the
number of
because
you want there's not another better
number
to for like winning championships oh
listen listen
different numbers have different
frequencies some numbers you want
associated with love some numbers you
want to associate with fear
13 is like Friday the 13th it's very
symbolic of fear so again you have one
main Federal Reserve Bank in Washington
DC and 12 more all across the country
you understand what they're trying to do
they're trying to implement that OnePlus
12 system Jesus and his 12 disciples you
understand what I'm trying to show yeah
I'm showing you how they're doing this
in religion I'm showing you how they're
doing this in banking I'm showing you
how they're doing this in every day
Society think about this
banking Federal Reserve one main twelve
the foul in the United States of America
12 other Banks Jesus Christ one Twelve
Apostles astrology one sign 12 one son
12 signs
it's everywhere around you if you all
you got to do is start paying attention
you talk about energy and stuff to like
someone that doesn't believe in this at
all how would you explain energy
to someone who doesn't believe in this
like energy like so what made me really
believe in energy and start seeing life
differently rather than just like this
Matrix world how we're perceived to see
it it's like I took psychedelics and
that like kind of mushrooms yes that's
the one usually people take yeah and
that like opened my mind to like this
isn't this world isn't just what we see
like every single mushroom trip I've had
I've taken something new out of it and
recognize that there's different energy
frequencies moving around how do you
explain uh effects to a person who's
never had it
again like the feeling how do you
explain that you can't explain it to a
virgin you know I like to tell people
um sometimes you can't see things but
you can feel it
and the best way for me to explain is
this
you can't see the wind
but if you put your hand outside the
window you can feel it
so there's certain things on this side
that you can actually feel without
seeing and I would ask everyone out
there who seems to be a comedian to open
your eyes and start looking at your
numerology and astrology because I'm the
one talking to billionaires not you I
was the one who was invited to the White
House not you I was the one who left the
Warriors win championship after
Championship not you so again this stuff
works if people actually pay attention
and do the push-ups I mean people want
to be funny out there do your own work
again when it at the end of the day
I want people to understand that you
have to do the work I can guide you but
you have to do it yourself
I have another question yes sir so a lot
of people see three numbers in a row
very very frequently personally they're
called angel numbers so I I personally
see 444 at least five five different
times a day some people see three
through three I just saw one one in the
chat what are the reasons that people
see these so three numbers so here's the
thing that cannot be coincidence no no
of course not um here's the thing
everyone sees those numbers most people
just aren't aware of it they think of
it's a coincidence you have a soul and
your soul has evolved to the point where
you can see the Matrix It signals this
is all virtual reality it's called a
matrix but the Matrix talks and its
language is numbers so it sends certain
numbers out there and if you know how to
interpret them you know what they mean
so for instance when it comes down to uh
let's say three three three three is the
number of communication so when anyone
sees those three numbers together they
have to basically start communicating
more uh whatever remains necessary
whether it be going to a party you have
have to be more social if someone sees
555 it might be a baby on the way uh
when it comes down to it five is the
number of Sexual Energy so sometimes
when people see that when people see
666's number of family so again most
people think that's some kind of oh my
God a lot of people think that's a
negative number is that why they make it
it's so negative because they're against
the family exactly so it's not just that
but think about this way 666 is not the
number of the devil okay there might be
a devil I'm not saying he doesn't exist
but 666 is not the number 666 is number
and time itself 60 minutes in an hour
six and zero six sixty uh uh seconds
seconds in a minute six and zero and six
and 24 hours a day there's your 666.
very simple what's up with um 31 days
and 12 months 31 days and 12 months they
should go back to 13 and
um 28 they should go back to 13 months
and 28 days uh the 28 days is when the
moon goes around to match the woman's
menstrual cycle
they should go back to that um the
reason they changed it is to manipulate
the energies
so it used to be 28 days to a month
every single day every single month 13
months and 28 days that's what it used
to be and they changed it to the
Gregorian calendar to manipulate the
energies so do you follow if they if
because we're following what's that
calendar called Gregorian so we're
following this now and you base people's
um personalities off of birthdays on
them ask me why though why it's very
simple because if six seven billion
people in the world it can believe
believe that today is uh September 16th
that's exactly what the environment The
Matrix is going to do so that's why
people's energy is going to match that
day because everyone's manifesting that
calendar itself this stuff is deep and
and again this
different way I guess
they understand that but at the end of
the day do you want to evolve
do you actually want to evolve because
this is the future this is what's going
to be going and replacing religion not
just Christianity not just Islam all of
it because at the end of the day you
have to add both
you have to understand this if you want
to evolve in a life why did January 1st
of year zero happen on that day
probably because the elite decided that
was the best day to do it and they did
on certain way lines there's certain
like points in the Earth where there's
chakras in the leyline points and they
probably did it because they knew if
they did it that day would be the best
effect remember how I told you off
camera I did everything in 2023 to blow
up they probably use the same strategy
for whatever reason they did it
hmm
and Jesus wasn't
[Music]
damn 9 11 again police code for
what do you tear and stuff like that why
are why are numbers shaped the way they
are that that has influence too right
goals matter everything I'll give you
one I'll give you one one
when it comes down to numbers
five is the number of change
okay if you have a five open on both
sides
it's open
it's right in the middle so the the
shape of the number tells you a lot
about the people's personalities because
people who are fives are very
open-minded
it's right there in the shape
uh you know a lot of people who are
overweight have some six energy look at
the shape
you understand how that works so I mean
people a lot of people with big egos
have a nine look at the shape big head
so again shapes matter uh
this is all there guys you gotta put in
the work so you talked about the
Gregorian calendar and how like since
everyone believes in it that's what
gives it the power are there any other
examples like that in society
um like everyone believes in it and
that's what gives it the power I would
say it's only big things because you
have a lot of people believing in it
you understand
um
a lot of people believe in capitalism
now
it works uh before a lot of people
believe in communism
and that didn't work so well at least
they tried it
um usually it has to do more with big
things
like calendars and things of that nature
but the power of manifestation is real
yo you know what I didn't even think
about I was just thinking so like you
know how a very common price is 19.99 I
was just gonna ask you because the way
they exp yeah the way they explain that
is because it's just below 20 so it's
like a psychological thing and then as I
was thinking that I was like holy [__]
it's 19.99 1999 yeah 28 to 98 money and
again of like for instance 28 is the
number of money he brought this up so
let me give you an examples uh the
richest man in the world Elon Musk born
on 28th he replaced Bill Gates who is
the richest man on earth born on the
28th did you know that six of the top 23
people in the world 23 richest people in
the world 6 are
that's insane again think of the
mathematical probability of that now
some people could say yo Gary that's not
enough okay what's the most valuable
sports franchise in the world today
Cowboys founded on the 11th 20th
the biggest uh asset manager in the
world it is Vanguard Vanguard is founded
5-1 1975 adds up to 28. uh Bill Gates
excuse me I'm sorry Steve Jobs uh born
224 in 1955 opened up Apple founded 4-1
1976 28 28 the richest cast rich company
in the world uh we're talking Anna
Nicole Smith you remember that word
right yeah okay uh she married a
billionaire married on the 28th
you understand how this works this is
this this is not me hallucinating this
is not me oh Gary's smoking some [__] no
it has nothing to do with it this is
based in fact if you choose
to accept the challenge you know and
actually try to evolve cool if you think
this is [__] that's cool too because
at the end of the day I still got way
more money than you and my wife is a lot
hotter than yours as well what about the
times that you fall asleep and wake up
in the morning what about it what does
that have anything to do with numerology
uh I don't think numerology works in the
dream world I think that's a completely
different realm what do you think about
the dream world what's your take I
believe that can you remember your
dreams or do you lose a dream yeah I
mean sometimes I remember my dreams I
mean hell I've done everything from you
know uh
atrial projection to remote viewing I
don't recommend people do stuff like
that with time because you've like
purposely done astral production
projection of course where you go above
and you look at your body laying there
I'm not sure it's like that in the
movies but you do definitely do have
out-of-body experiences and it's it's
not like you're over there staring
looking your body it's just everything
around you is different you see what's
not you see like for instance a dog can
only see black and white humans can see
colors but there's different colors out
there that we can't even see it's in the
Spectrum so again this is what
numerology astrology is I'm actually
trying to help you guys understand that
if you look at the bigger Spectrum you
might be able to see something more the
dream world in my opinion
um everyone has to sleep
no matter if you're animal human and
insect you have to sleep
and at the end of the day I think when
you sleep you're actually giving energy
away because think about when you sleep
you leap
Energy starts with e sleep two e's leap
so basically when we go to the dream
world
I think something is taking our energy
and it's like we're teleporting yo
that's actually crazy too I would never
kill myself but my roommate is really
diving into the raw diet and like the
way our bodies are truly meant to be
without Jabs and everything and he's
discovered that realistically our bodies
if we're in our most natural state only
need two to three hours of sleep so a
Tesla would go to sleep for about two 20
minutes wake up and go back to sleep in
20 for work for three hours go back to
sleep for 20 minutes that's what he did
like all day three hours 20 minutes oh
he did three hours four hours up not for
20 minutes I actually wanted to talk
about Tesla
um not sure how deep we can go into it
because we're on YouTube and whatnot but
I know he talked about the importance of
number three as a building block can you
expand on that uh three is is this a
third dimensional plan
so the Earth everything we're on this is
3D the next level up is four so right
now we're in the third dimensional plane
so number three has a lot to do with it
for instance one is male energy two is
female energy one plus two is three
three is the childlike energy that's
what child starts with c and sees the
third letter
how did people even like
organize all of this stuff you know you
know what I consider myself a genius
that I figure out these codes without
joining the Freemasons without any help
without any Mentor but to actually put
this system together it's like the most
advanced coding of all time wow actually
put this together
it makes you think is it if it like it
makes you think is a human even possible
of putting this stuff together because
I'm usually the smartest person in the
room yeah again you know I I am arrogant
deal with it
um and I couldn't even fathom putting
this system together no one I know has
the ability to do something like this I
mean to make sure everything fits uh
genius starts with g g is the seventh
letter uh Gamble starts with G what
number do they always uh start showing
in the casinos seven G is the seventh
letter you understand how it works uh
how many cards in the deck 52 five and
two or seven so again it's everywhere
it's absolutely everywhere no matter
what you look at it's there
let's look at sports Michael Jordan born
uh 217 1963. he's an 11 life path he
Mentor Kobe Bryant Kobe is another 11
born 823 1978 he mentored Kyrie Irving
another 11 born to uh 323 1992. so 11 to
11 to 11. what do you think this is a
coincidence
start looking at numbers they never lied
unlike the people over here in your chat
board
um when it comes to wow you probably
have a lot of NPCs there's a ton of
NPCs in this chat man so we know uh the
messages are gonna resonate with NPCs so
if you think this is a fraud if you want
to talk jokes if you want to talk [__]
that's fine you are a NPC because you
refuse to take the challenge to better
yourself when it comes to knowledge to
evolve to the point where you know what
maybe there's something a little bit out
there that you don't know
yeah it's kind of sad to see but it's
okay yeah
the people it resonates with
it'll uh yeah we have a soul if this
resonates you congratulations you have a
soul you want to do another trick let's
see it okay
go like this you have any anything on
you okay go with this all right
now take your hands like this a little
bit apart just a little bit and then go
back but don't touch them no further
apart not that fast it feels like it
feels like a magnet don't touch it
exactly feels like a magnet what the
[__] exactly hold on hold on just keep
it right there now I want you people at
home to do the same thing take your
hands and go like this but don't touch
don't touch close together like this a
little bit apart a little bit apart you
should feel some kind of energy you
should feel some kind of magnetism and
if you don't you're NPC because you
don't have a you don't have a soul do
you understand that you do not have a
soul if you can't feel it come here put
your hands right here you mean okay
do you feel that
yes
that's weird this is how stuff works you
have energy in your body
by the way they don't teach you this
stuff in schools what about 10 fingers
ten toes four limbs that's yeah
anything about that I mean people have
five senses you know
huh
obviously I have another good question
porn so I'm not sure if there's
numerology related to this but I know
the elites try to get us addicted to
porn from a young age to pretty much
destroy our soul is there anything
numerology related to that stuff or
maybe our frequencies
yeah
um I would never kill myself
porn is given to you for free
there's some other stuff that was given
to you for free that we won't mention
that didn't turn out to be so good for
you
if
the elite are giving you something for
free there is something wrong with it
there is something really wrong with it
porn breaks down the family unit so what
happens is
um the guy starts being a uh addicted to
porn and he doesn't give his wife sex
he doesn't give his wife sex she's
mostly going to go out there and find it
from someone else so it basically
destroys the family unit I believe porn
should be banned I believe only fan
girls should be put out of business and
if I'm ever in a position of power you
best believe I'm gonna do that because I
believe in the family see what you don't
understand is you Christians who are
listening to me or mostly on the same
team
I mean I pretty much believe in the same
thing they do banned porn go Trump stuff
like that I believe in the same thing
you do but there's a reason you vote for
Donald Trump and I know him
there's a reason for that there's a
reason you vote for and I get invited to
the White House because obviously I know
things that are valuable to people in
positions of power and I'm taking I'm
taking the time out my day to join your
man over here to try to teach you some
things and if you think this is a joke
congratulations when it's your time to
be judged at least they'll say yo
someone actually tried to show you the
way she won't actually try to show you
the path but you refuse to take it whose
problem is that
it's your own that's actually something
that Muslims say they say if you were
never exposed to Islam and then you
don't convert then it's not your fault
but if you're exposed to it and then you
don't convert then um you have to pay
the consequences in the afterlife
you know Islam is a beautiful religion
uh when things are falling apart
when you have nothing but degeneracy in
the world when you have women who have a
higher body count at their age when you
have women who are allowing their bodies
to be used like rental cars and then
demand respect you know you cannot build
families with these type of women so
when you have degeneracy at this scale
like you do with America and some other
Western Nations welcome Islam welcome
Islam because listen Islam is actually
confronting the problem
um you Christians especially in uh
America in Canada and you know some of
these other Western countries you have
done like the Lord of the Rings and you
have bet that [__] need you have bet
your knee to your enemy and they will do
whatever they want it they you can't
even bake a cake
it literally can't bake a cake but Islam
and the Muslims they're actually
standing up against people and they're
actually standing up against degeneracy
so right now is a perfect time for Islam
because Islam can fix a lot of the
problems there in society today the
problem is when you have a stable
Society like we did in the early late
1940s and the 1950s when people can
leave their cars and their you know
everything they didn't even have locks
on the door at that point Islam kind of
holds people back because Islam doesn't
even believe in reincarnation for God's
sake
I mean they'll tell you oh it is
reincarnation when you're a baby and
then you're born no that's not
reincarnation that's how the human
process works what makes you believe in
reincarnation like have you because
because I've seen people numerology
there's some people who are just older
Souls there's some people who are just
young souls and you cannot tell me with
any validity whatsoever that every soul
has the same mission
Every Soul does not have the same
Mission so if every soul doesn't have
the same mission that means they're
older souls and they're younger Souls
which means Islam is wrong
what do they call the devil's hour at
night
got three three a.m 3 A.M is there a
reason for that
um I would probably think that they're
trying to mock the Holy Trinity
really that's what I would believe they
were trying to do what what happened
first
what do you mean like what happened
does time go back infinitely
I like to answer questions I can say
with a hundred percent validity a
hundred percent fact where I could back
things up if I was to answer that
question it would be a theorem theorism
or a theory I can't tell you but yes I
do believe time is infinite
and the reason I believe that goes back
to math if you take uh one-third and
two-thirds and you turn them into from
fractions to decimals one a third to
decimals turns into point three three
three it goes on forever so I do believe
um based off that math that uh time and
space can be infinite what about like
prime numbers anything of course prime
numbers mean something
um there's a reason why you know certain
prime numbers keep showing up all the
time those are one of those things that
you have to do the work to figure out
why certain prime numbers are showing up
in history over and over and over and um
13 is a prime number isn't it
interesting isn't it yeah
that is interesting
well is there an NPC number
uh if it is I won't reveal do you tell
people do you tell people
um I guess you do like the negative
stuff that could happen in their lives
with numerology you give the mornings I
I I've told billionaires to get divorced
from their wives
and then did they ever not do it and
then the consequences paid yes uh there
was the minority owner of the Golden
State Warriors I always like to bring
this up
um he is born in 66 and I told him 1996
was a bad year and he's like no Gary it
was a good year I made money and I got
married I'm like are you still married
he's like no did she take your bag yes
so sometimes when you do things at the
wrong time they come back to kiss you
and that you know hurt you
so you like when you say like lay low in
your enemy year you mean just like like
maintenance do you know how the game of
football is played
uh yeah okay yeah you either run the
ball or you throw the ball right correct
okay so if you're in your enemy year
this is why I recommend if you're on
offense first down run the ball up the
middle
second down run the ball up the middle
third down run the ball up the middle
and then punt
that's how you play it safe that's how
you play conservative because if you try
to throw the ball downfield pick six
it's gonna hurt you if you take chances
in your enemy year it is going to hurt
you that's how the game is played how do
um professional athletes or these sports
teams use numerology is it incorporated
into the game itself like three periods
20 minutes I mean
um do I think they use numerology to set
up the games no I don't think they were
actually basing off that but I mean like
for instance um the NFL no one cares
about the NFL outside America absolutely
nobody correct uh inside America is the
number one sport why is that because
energy NFL was found in 1920 to year the
monkey and America was found in 1776 the
year of the monkey so again that's why
that is the number one sport in America
the energies match Saudi Arabia has been
America's greatest Ally in the Middle
East that's Arab Nation uh Saudi Arabia
was found in the Monkey air you know by
the way the monkey's friend is the rats
Israel founded 1948 the year the rat is
good friends with Saudi Arabia and good
friends with America so again you see
how this works if you choose not to
accept this information oh I mean hell I
can't help it if you're a mental [__]
how many different correlations do you
look for so I know you analyze like the
year the friends year you look at the
dates you add them up and then there's
like many many numbers inside so is it
more so like a matter of like some of
them are smaller energy amounts and then
if there's a bunch of different
correlations correct I'm starting to
pick it up it's it's it's it's reverse
engineering that's all it is man
um you just so you'll ever you'll
sometimes see something where it's like
correlation correlation correlation and
you're like holy [__] yeah time to put a
lot of money on it yeah so oh so that's
where you analyze like sports better
yeah there you go by the way I'm one of
those guys who actually winning
um Atlantic City and won 1.2 million in
a casino in three months off excuse me
in one month I was sports betting and
they threw me out as a matter of fact
three casinos in my life have thrown me
out because I want too much money so
again you guys can pray to your God I
will serve them and because I'm servant
of serving him I am thinking and because
I'm thinking I'm using cheat codes in
The Matrix to benefit me and the people
who actually want to listen
how did the casinos utilize numerology I
know we talked about this they say
Seven's a good number for luck actually
it's the exact opposite seven is the
unluckiest number that's why they're
always telling you Lucky Seven to Lucky
Seven because it's [__] exactly
and then what about hmm
interesting and even like the patterns
on the floors and stuff like that does
that oh that's that's more Masonic stuff
that's oh really uh Freemasons love
checkered floors black and white black
and white so black adds up to an 11 in
Gematria whether algae and so is white
so those two energy that's why they
always try to play black and white
people against each other because that's
the very emotional energy they don't try
to put they don't try to put the whites
against the Asians of course not so it's
always 11 verse 11. so I'll give you an
example they like to uh start
revolutions with people
um with the name of G
think about this who was the leader of
the American Revolution against Great
Britain
George George Washington
capital g capital G is the 33rd letter
so let's go like this oh because again
one equals a lowercase if you go to
capital capital B is the 28th letter
that's why billionaire starts with B
capital b 28 and capital G is 33. now
you understand why Tate likes to call
himself top G and he is kind of
influential isn't he do you think that
that has to do with numerology not just
because he's a gangster because he says
100 I've been talking about the Matrix
years before him I've been talking about
numerology astrology and my name has
been G for a long time my name is
actually Gary what do you think I
started gg33 for no reason it's in the
name it's in the name so again when it
comes down to uh G why'd the Freemasons
have it it's right in their logo a
capital G
what's up with the I like What's um
the Illuminati all I'll tell you about
it because I you know um want to make
sure I live a long time all I'll say
about this is there's a reason why I is
spelled e-y-e and why I spelled I
people have to figure out themselves
like I like like Capitol High there's a
reason for that
damn are we allowed to talk about
Freemasons on YouTube or is that
something that they shut up you can talk
about Freemasons
um I really am not familiar with
Freemasons and stuff at all um they used
to be very powerful back in the 1700s
they designed Washington DC like if you
go to Washington DC all the buildings
are designed basically by Freemasons the
whole Washington DC area is basically
designed by Freemasons
um but they're not powerful as they used
to be
um most masons in the
um you know in the year 2023 are just
usually laying in the woods
middle-aged white folks who just like to
get together with other people and you
know
you know talk and stuff
um the most power most Masons have is
maybe a a judge is a fellow Mason he'll
let him off on the speeding ticket these
people these people don't have real
power anymore they've been neutered
they've been uh they've had a Visa
vasectomy they don't have any real power
they did have power in the 1700s they
did have power in the 1800s they have
very very limited power now oh did
someone just say it
that has to do with it though obviously
if people think so interesting
why don't I give enough Clues yeah I
don't I don't I don't I sometimes I just
leave some breakfast I'm picking it up
like I'm analyzing the way your brain
works with this stuff and I'm able to
start seeing the correlations of course
2025 snake gear let's go by the way
there is a lie in the in the Bible
snakes are the most honorable
trustworthy people people who are born
in snake years it's it just shocks me
that they have this term called snaked
he snaked yeah because
the I've known people for for over a
decade in gg33 and the most loyal people
have always been snakes
every single time so why do you think
they do that I think it's basically the
you know
do the exact opposite to make people
fear something same thing with 666
that's the number four and then what
that adds up to not a 6 12 18 add one
and eight that's nine and then what is
nine again and it's the number of the
adaptability
interesting what about the rainbow flag
they cut off a color to make it six
Stripes intentional yes 100 have you
seen the straight flag
you want me to show you yeah let me see
the stream it's actually hilarious this
is a this is a straight up joke
a straight flag I I've been talking
about this so like the Liberals they're
very good at building like an emotional
defense wall so that you can't attack
their arguments or else you're a bad
person so like protect trans kids sounds
like a good thing and then it's like oh
protect the ability
you have to basically think of this
anything the government promotes is a
noble Act is a hidden evil
think of it that way anything the
government promotes real strong it's a
hidden evil yeah like you you being gay
is now more heroic than joining the
military you wearing the mask now you're
brave and you're putting it 100 when
it's desensitizing and it's seeing
everyone as numbers like 100 I hope you
guys are actually listening to this bro
it's like it's pretty upsetting to me
that so many of you are just like
close-minded but look at this [__]
one two three five Stripes I'm not sure
if that has any meaning to it but that's
the ugliest [__] in the world I'm gonna
be black and white I mean wait one two
three four five six so there's actually
six on this one maybe why would it be
black and white why would it be black
and white unless you want that's I just
talked about black and white is Masonic
the checkered floors all the time and
again I'm not saying miss all Masons are
bad people I hope you guys don't take
that I'm not one of these guys who
blames Masons for everything
um I think they're just pretty much they
used to be powerful and now they devolve
to basically a local fraternity for Old
Men hmm
that's interesting all right so I don't
think we really went over my like um my
birthday at all on stream okay so I
won't go into everything because I don't
want your enemies to know what your weak
and strong points are thank you but I
will say one thing
um you're and you're you're born the
goat year and your enemy is the ox now
how do I prove this because it's one
thing to say it but it's another thing
to prove it I'm not a woman who's been
divorced three times you're talking
about blah blah blah Western astrology
I'm gonna prove it to you Russia was uh
basically founded in 1991 that's when
the Soviet Union collapsed Russia was
formed
1991 is the year to go who is Russia's
enemy
in in the 90s the USA right now who's
their enemy but they use a proxy
I mean us nature
oh yeah NATO is a proxy because NATO's
expanded exactly what is NATO when was
NATO founded
1949 the year of the ox so we have
Russia versus Nato Ox versus goats you
see how this works in every single day
of life let's talk about the main Ox in
history his name was Hitler
Hitler was uh born 1889. uh he had
Europe completely dominated in 1941 1941
is the year the snake he's oxed their
friends his enemy year hit in 1943
1943 is the year the goat he lost
Stalingrad he lost curse by the way
Kursk is the biggest tank battle in
history it happened 1943 after he lost
that it was over it was just a matter of
time before he lost it all happened in
his enemy year so again example after
example after example so again people
can say what they want you cannot
disprove anything I say not a damn thing
I'm not going to read that comment for
sure
that's like a No-No
um what are some other correlations with
like words so you talked about maybe I
don't want to bring up the ones you
brought off camera but like uh
one you can't uh say the word truth
without the word hurt
the word hurt is within the word because
the truth hurts exactly the truth hurts
and you can't say Bible without the word
lie
oh I'm sorry did I hurt people's
feelings out there I'm so sorry you
cannot say the word bible without the
word lie you know what else you can't
say the word alien without the word lie
let's take the a off the end off and you
have a lie right in there so again words
tell you a lot if you're paying
attention
um would you agree that America is
Israel's best friend yes would most
people in this chat room agree that
America is Israel's best friend can
people say yes okay we got one yes can
we get another yes or come on let's get
some involvement here
man this this crowds I guess I beat him
to death
they've been talking bad [__] and now
all of a sudden oh oh this guy might be
making a little sense so here's why I
bring that up
Jerusalem
you can't spell Jerusalem without the
word USA
yo
everything is hitting in plain sight
it's your choice if you go to through
Lifeline it's up to you man I'm not I'm
better than that are you we figure it
out soon won't we the only one that I've
noticed or like that I saw on social
media was a race car is race car
backwards yeah and if you look at social
media the word social has the word CIA
in it and the CIA has been running
social media for a long long time the
CIA has plants as influencers all sorts
of good stuff and that's why they use
the word social media because it has the
word CIA in it so again words within
words
yeah let's hear one more the word
dishwasher has her in it yeah that's
crazy that's crazy
it is what it is don't hate me don't
hate the messenger I'm just telling you
what it is oh my God that's gold like
why would they do this is it an energy
thing so like it's all energy it's all
energy and they do it subconsciously
people don't even recognize it bro why
is ciicia
sensual intelligence agencies but you
know they have the one that has those
initials and they put it in words
and it has I'm assuming it has some new
numerological of course yeah let's not
talk about the CIA on YouTube yeah you
don't want this watch too much in
Langley talk about let me hear like some
um LGBT stuff with uh why why do you
think people are gay
um mostly propaganda propaganda I mean
people are not born gay right I don't
believe they are I believe that like for
instance I believe if someone is born in
Saudi Arabia they'll be Muslim I believe
it's someone's born in San Francisco
they have a much higher chance to be gay
environmentally you know I think the
environment matters
um you know there I have some strong
issues on the subject I'm not sure this
is the right platform for it okay
I mean you couldn't talk about gay stuff
on YouTube not the stuff I want to talk
about no all right I have another weird
one maybe there's some there maybe
there's some correlation to this date so
like I used to be a semi-professional
fortnite player and all I would do oh my
God so many people are in fortnite
everyone came from fortnite everyone so
many people made it out the mud with
fortnite and then they got into web
three that's nuts oh
many people who are influencers do you
think made it out of fortnite a ton so
many different people and you know what
that's crazy you know what a big
correlation is crazy a lot of us were
the um we're called igl so end game
leaders
and um so we would like lead the pack
the other guys would just be really good
at the video game so all the igos
basically quit fortnite once like the
the pandemic started as I like to call
it and we all went in and just started
making bread and getting into social
media and stuff that [__] bro good [__]
let me see the way let me find this find
a way I I think it's like winning the
lotto to uh do something yourself after
playing video games that's like when the
freaking Lotto bro
people say it's I've seen MPC game I
actually learned a lot of life lessons
playing video games it sounds kind of
cringe to say but like you have to leave
you have to lead you learn how to be a
capitalist
somewhat like you have to learn how to
go you have to learn how to manage a
team you have to learn how to practice
different aspects of your life how to
not stay emotional if something goes
wrong you have to analyze what movie
made what women definitely couldn't do
that no there's no there's no
professional women that are like
actually oh really what a shock no women
can handle pressure no no you're a
sexist don't do that come on guys
dishwash her exactly that's a Clipper
let's get that go away what everyone say
there's a reason it's called dishwasher
okay I mean let's keep it real bad words
don't lie that's crazy but so what I
found the screenshot that I wanted to
pull up so finally once I decided to
quit fortnite basically I was like okay
I'm like practicing my aim I'm
practicing my in-game leading skills
like I'm analyzing all these different
aspects I'm doing tasks to improve them
and basically build my character okay
and so then one day I was like why the
[__] not just do this with like business
like start watching real estate videos
start watching econ videos try stuff and
just like build these different aspects
of my own character did you broke Keys
hear that
I hope they did did you this was like
say it louder for the people in the back
because you know there's a lot of people
out there criticizing you and me they
don't have two pennies to rub together
I'm surprised you can afford the
internet they listen to this I mean I
mean dead seriously they're getting ads
every five minutes
so the first video I decided to watch I
actually have a screenshot of it and it
was Graham Stefan on one of his videos
and it was at 207 oh wait
207 am which I don't know if that's much
significant but it was January 11th
on 2021 so January did this video blow
up no like this is I just found this
screenshot this is like the first video
that I watched that was like I'm done
with this fortnite [__] let me go hard
with like it was a very emotional
decision
it was like it was like it was like it
almost like remember what I told you
about the 11th
yeah didn't happen on the 11th yeah
and and I'm assuming because it's
January that's a triple
it's like more energy you're wearing it
you're learning I'm a good learner
that's what people say maybe that has to
do it unlike those these people in the
chat room man I'm losing hope for him
man I'm losing hope you know when I do a
stream with someone you start
understanding what the average IQ of
their followers are by the chat comments
man but I mean some of you people are
really disappointing I mean I mean what
can you say man Joe Biden's president
too yeah it's it is what it is man I try
to get if I can at least help like a few
different people that have souls make it
out of the the race that's all that
really matters at the end of the day
agreed my friend agreed anyways brother
we did a nice little podcast today yeah
man you're cooking we got some good
clips for sure
110 floors on the 11th flight 11. you
really want me to go in this field one
more time I feel like I didn't know you
did that no he was cooking that Spiel do
you guys have any many freaking types oh
my God and he finally even snico said he
memorized that Spielberg I I just meant
I just spit it out basically
uh 911 happened 11. first point to hit
the World Trade Center was fight 11. 911
again not 9 11. uh New York City 11
letters New York the 11th State of Union
uh Shanksville Pennsylvania one of the
planes went down 11. the Pentagon 11. it
goes on and on and on
all right
like one more question we'll take and
then we got to get going a good one
don't be some don't have some dumb [__]
here for a while man I'm not expecting
much out of this uh numb skull group if
he's so smart get a reading uh you can
just look me listen I blew up this year
on Twitter all right well not on Twitter
excuse me I blew up this year on IG I
blew up this year on YouTube not like
this man but I'm getting there I blew up
this year on Tick Tock I got way over a
million followers I got about 35 people
who work for me if you want a reading
for me you better be rich okay because I
don't charge you a way of five figures
but if you want from my students who
have much more affordable pricing who've
been trained by me go for it it's
basically 188 gg33 classes put in gg33
class a hashtag anywhere and if you want
to get involved in gg33 Academy well
that's my um school where I basically
have my students doing the teaching he
will have an affiliate link for you guys
very soon and you you guys can join
through that and basically level up guys
level up in life
you know here's the thing
you have to challenge yourself to be the
best version of yourself than you can be
one of those is basically finding the
right woman
you know that that's one of the things
that levels people up but one of those
things is whenever you can't figure
something out
try to attempt to
because there are answers out there that
honestly you are not aware of
and if you honestly start looking at
dates at numbers just like this man he's
already picking up on stuff you've seen
this man's Evolution through this
podcast things are starting to make
sense now are you the same or is this
man better than you
if I got a guess I'm thinking you're
better than these people but that's just
me now I'm not better than any of them
bro anyone can open their mind I would
like to think you want to make it back
I'm not going to make that I'm not gonna
make that bad bro I know you are yo yo
so would you say start talking about
body they back real quick because he
doesn't have any faith in you he just
wants to be nice I have absolutely no
faith in you but thank you for watching
yeah bro thank you so much for coming on
I didn't really see any good questions
Fitness is there anything you want to
add about Fitness because uh I'm not the
I don't I'm not the expert at that I'm
45 when I was 23 I would have whooped
any one of your asses yeah
five years old man yeah and again
um next year if I get like 10 million
followers and I can get paid off it then
we'll see what happens I'm not I'm not
the one to ask for that there's way much
more qualified people go to Tech for
that [__] I mean hell man even he can
tell you how to lift the dumbbell
all right bro I appreciate it that's all
right brother peace